- All right y'all, the hours
almost up, but not quite yet.
Let's check out something
that's sure to make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
When a Florida special
ed teacher realized most
of the students at her
school had never seen snow.
She came up with a very
cool way to give them an
up close and personal experience.
She called her sister in Kentucky.
Asked her to build a snowman
and ship it to her class.
Low it the what?
That's crazy.
Like, how do you do that?
Low and behold, Lucky the
Snowman made the 800 mile journey
to the total delight of her students.
- Aww are you serious?
(teacher gasping)
- He made it.
- (Guest) He made it.
(teacher clapping)
He made it.
(crowd clapping)
- Aww.
- We have this remarkable
teacher, Robin and her sister
Amber on the line right now.
What's up ladies?
(crowd cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
First of all, Amber, like
what did you think when
Robin asked you to build
and ship a snowman?
I don't think that's
ever been asked, ever.
- Well, when my sister
puts me up for a challenge
I don't back down at all.
So never in a million years did I think
that we would have such a perfect snow to
build such a perfect little snowman.
But on January 8th,
we had snow that equaled about 10 inches.
- Wow.
- So, out I went to build a snowman.
So, I put him together.
He was about 18 inches tall.
Complete with blueberry
eyes, blueberry buttons for,
for his shirt.
And I also put little sticks
for his arms -
- (audience awing)
and his carrot nose.
I brought out a box and
it was lined in styrofoam
and took lots and lots of ice packs,
put him inside there, packaged
him up and sent him down
to the shipping station.
And believe it or not -
- He made it. He made it.
when I shipped him out, a piece
of my heart, went with him.
I felt connected to this little guy.
So off he went -
- Aww.
and I caught myself
being up all night long
tracking to watch to make
sure he made it Tampa.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's awesome.
(audience clapping)
So Robin, were you worried
that he'd be melted by the
time you opened the box?
- Listen, when I got that
box, it was like Fort Knox.
He was taped up like Fort Knox,
but I could feel, my heart
was just pounding and I
could feel him actually.
He was cold.
So, I opened it up and I peeled
it back and there he was.
He was perfect.
So I rushed him down to the
classroom so that the kids
could see him and they were so excited.
So, he's excited to meet you.
So here he is, he's doing great.
The kids -
- Oh my gosh.
just love him Kelly.
(audience clapping)
- I go in, they're so excited to see him
and he's brought such joy
to our school.
And we're just so happy.
They wanna, you know, I
take him outta the lot
of the times the kids wanna
wave at him and they wanna know
if he's like Olaf, is
he gonna come to life?
(audience chattering)
But, he has brought such joy.
And I, I can't tell you
the joy that he's brought
to us here at our school.
And you know, when I think
about him, I get a little
I get a little emotional.
I'm not gonna lie.
I get emotional when I think about him.
- Aw, that's so sweet.
It is magical.
I remember the first one made a snowman
with my kids and they
really hadn't been in snow.
It's a magical little moment.
So that's really cool that
you did that for your kids.
Thank you so much, Robin.
Thank you, Amber.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all ladies
our season long partner Pilot Pen Makers.
A Frixion that go to a erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like y'all.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
That's $500 each.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
This is such a sweet
kind thing that you did.